no no no the other thing
do you regret the capital steez thing
with joey
don't zoom in on my face when i'm
smiling
i'm see you getting raw emotions out of
me i'm just asking i'm just asking if
not at that at that time i mean i mean i
know you were on your troy have [ __ ]
like in in retrospect do you regret that
at all oh he's on i'm just me man i mean
like
listen man this how i feel
what can can you uh bring the people up
to people without what i say and why i
said it because i want to make sure
because just like well you didn't know
that that was in response to the control
freestyle i want to make sure that so
the joey thing i felt like
like what the fact is
well listen i don't know why you said it
i know that at the time you don't know
why i know that you guys are going back
and forth to who was selling more
records independently
right that was kind of the it wasn't
back and forth i wasn't concerned with
who was selling more i guess independent
out of new york uh
that wasn't me i wasn't back and forth
you had brought up
the fact that
his wanted one of the guys in pro era
capital stees had killed himself and
said some un un
probably some not nice things about
about that situation
this isn't look you got the clips on
your wall you got 50 center in your wall
you don't have the locks here didn't
they talk about 50s mother they died
but what was it what what let me ask you
guys again pushing because
this has been like five or six years oh
don't do that look i don't know what i'm
trying to do is know what i'm trying to
do is ask you like what like like for
people who don't know and even refresh
my memory what was the origin of the
issue with joey where that that
statement before before before i forget
i want to set the premise on it because
it's very important in the environment
the rap that that i grew up listening to
as a kid is
clips this is pusha t he's one of the
greatest he
then he go crazy on drake man producer
who got having
or something okay
50 cent
he was going
nuts on everybody and they went nuts on
him it is it is what it is
and this is tupac hit him up and like no
no you got these people on your wall
right no i do and the [ __ ] that they
said was
the [ __ ] they said was
but i think that their issues with the
with the other side of the the
exchange were probably uh at least a lot
more stronger than what your at least
what your issues might have been with
joey no well well the issue started with
joey was i was minding my business
just doing my thing independent i was
only just independent and i always said
bsb wreck is the number one independent
label out of new york
you know what i'm saying and then um
i don't know i think he might have said
something about it or maybe not i don't
remember but i know something like his
um
a friend of his came on a record and he
was like yeah
and such and such so more records than
choi
now again
i dropped my i dropped my project major
without a deal
and you know they try to like you seem
like people always coming for me you
know i mean because it's like a bunch of
fake
people
and when they see the rail they don't
want to really shine because then you
make them look funny if you bring real
diamonds around [ __ ] with fake
[ __ ] then they start looking funny so
well let's get them out of here
so they said oh troy ave took a l i only
sold a couple thousand records or
whatever right that wasn't really true
i dropped my i dropped my album on a
friday when everybody else would drop me
[ __ ] on a tuesday yeah we talking about
pure record souls for that week i
actually sold fourteen thousand for
people who don't know this was before it
got switched to fridays this before
people are going to be in the comments
like man [ __ ] comes out so back back
then it was tuesday's musical drop
so when you drop on a friday
you're not getting it full you're not
getting a full week and then i didn't
care about that i'm independent i'm like
man i'm gonna drop all the money i'm
gonna keep saying music exactly i don't
i don't believe in that pop [ __ ] and
apologize
i suck at [ __ ] right you don't pop [ __ ]
and then when you see you playing that
yola sit and talk it out yo it's so good
that [ __ ] should've never happened why
did it happen
and then you tell me why it happened why
would somebody i'm sure i've never took
a shot at nobody out of nowhere or no
records for what for clout just for what
because when you disrespect then you
open the door to be down with all the
disrespect that comes with it
so do you feel like they was down for
all the disrespect that comes with it or
was they just i mean how do you feel i
mean i think that be honest
let me tell you something this is what
happened so that happened
i remember that line you're saying now
now i remember the joey line you're
talking about which happened first also
not at not even in the same ballpark of
disrespect as what you came and retorted
with i didn't know we played ballparks
at districts but listen but listen
but but i know but what i want to get to
is like because for a long time
so like i'll give you an example once
that happened you had a record at that
time that was getting pushed to radio i
don't remember which song it was
i don't remember either but i don't
remember it yes
it might have been but it wasn't
i don't know what it was but you had a
record that was getting insulted in the
play yeah it was offended i think i was
like
but i'm like
my boy in minneapolis who's playing your
record on the radio right
the station called uh go 95 96 3.
um
and he calls me and he's like yo we're
like supporting troy and like yo he's
like disrespecting people who like
have families that have gone through
suicide [ __ ] like what
how how how are they taking it that
person and the crazy [ __ ] is i really
[ __ ] with him whenever i would go out
there we would tap in like i really
[ __ ] with him so this is that's the
prime minister he's calling me and i'm
like
yo man i could just talk to hoevane
you know but how but but you know i
think i talk to you right from a record
of somebody starting something with me
and then i'd respond i think it was just
that
i spoke to you too yeah but how does
that affect other people in positions of
doing their job like it's not a personal
thing if you got a good record you got a
good record throw it on and [ __ ] with it
this record is just a diss record in
response to what they said to me and it
went crazy but
how how in the [ __ ] world is that
okay for somebody's personal feelings
about what two other men have a problem
with
to affect
you pushing they [ __ ] or you playing
just don't push you just play it
regularly it's a good record right right
everybody everybody loved the record i
remember which i forget which record it
was i don't know you had
during that era you had a few so oh and
maybe she belongs to the game maybe doo
doo doo doo doo it might have been
she belongs to the game i feel like i
don't know
whatever but no but so let me ask you
this do you feel like did you do you
feel like that that specific line
[Music]
like you feel like i went too far you
know no no no i i well you obviously
don't feel like you went too far but do
you feel like you know
i didn't say that do you feel like it uh
affected you
and your career at all negatively
um because because that one anecdotal
situation we just talked about about a
single radio station in minnesota that's
nice but there's other no there's other
people but that's what i felt like
because i feel like a lot of people were
like oh troy we're off that [ __ ]
like he's he he took it too far like
yeah because they they just they just
wait they
they was never really
[ __ ] with me because i
i stand for everything that they don't i
stand for independence i stand for being
confident they'll call my confidence
cocky they'll call my independent cells
mediocre when in reality my independence
sales are superior to yours because i
need more money for dollar you know
like i feel like that was just a way for
people to come out and have something to
say like how any problem with between
two men it's more just look at chicago
they talk about smoking dead ops
oh i don't listen who i do not disagree
right now
especially like in jacksonville [ __ ] is
[ __ ] you film me to who i smoke but
it but it been
music been disrespectful
i think people just looked at it as like
joey's like this kid was just making
dope young rap music you're from new
york and maybe as opposed to like you
guys having an issue and like it being
like a thing like
you know and at the time you guys were
definitely
you know
your your guys's rises were parallel to
each other not not related to each other
it wasn't really parallel he was way uh
he was way ahead of me already i just
mean in terms of like you guys are both
up and coming in new york city your
energy was a lot different obviously but
like joey badass could have been on new
york city the album and that would have
made sense and it would have sounded
good right
no he couldn't have been on new york
city album not that album i'm not i'm
just mean in terms of like i'm not sure
i was disappointed those type of beats
you know what i'm saying like [ __ ] no
hell no absolutely not how
how where you know who's on new york
city album tell me if you you can't tell
me one person that no let alone put on
you can't tell me one person that i
could take off to play morning no i'm
not talking okay i'll say that i'm not
saying that he could fit where he cannot
you could pull all the songs up there's
no way that music is different they was
making backpack rap music i think he was
making traditional new york 90s boombap
[ __ ] traditional new york nineties boys
i don't make i don't make 90s yeah i'm
not but i'm not saying you but i'm i'm
making [ __ ] incarcerated skull faces
i'm making capital punishment i'm making
i think i'm making dumb and i don't
think joey
i don't think joey [ __ ] was far from
that wheelhouse how bro bro those are
two different types of hip-hop
i'm telling i'm i grew up in that space
those are two
this is listen
has most def and jay-z
um
has done [ __ ] uh well i never heard
tyler carley on the jay-z album
never not on a jc album but they've been
on on a record together they get by
remix that's come on give it a go you
know hip-hop kev don't do that come on
can't you mean if jay was on to the
quality [ __ ] so most def make dope ass
music right
so even tyler mcquality be flowing
but them two type of albums are
different they they it doesn't go so you
can't say he could have been on new york
city the album no or major what i did no
[ __ ] way it it's not that
joey has records with all the guys that
are on new york city of the album i'm
pretty sure when no i i'll call cap
some thousands of jury i'm a fighter
who's on the outside but i got to dance
with me i'll bet right now who was who
else on the album who's on prodigy
cameron fat joke
rayquan
um
pusha t
um
no not push t jd kiss fabulous uh mad p
i i bet you anything there's no there's
never no cap with joey ass i don't i
don't just do to assume you know how
people just throw out a fact
i guess the point i'm trying to say is i
feel like you like divided y'all so much
like and i think some people made it had
me maybe thought it was unnecessary
what was that there's no rules to a
reaction that's fair if if somebody
comes and slaps you right now in your
face what would you do kev somebody just
randomly walks in and i react like what
would your reaction be just randomly but
violence like like what kind of violence
i don't know uh a punch uh
a punch is more severe than a slap right
this is true
but do you not think that some of the
things you were saying in the interviews
were kind of like
like he could have loosely taken them as
like
yo was he talking about us
i was never wit and what in it there was
never nobody we were talking about like
like being the biggest like like rapper
out of new york you know i said i'm the
number one independent rapper out of new
york i still am to this day
but how i'm only speaking facts there's
nothing wrong with speaking your facts i
don't listen i'm i'm just trying i'm
independent when you see my [ __ ] it's a
bsb record but you did but you did feel
did you did you feel like some of the
industry turned their back on you when
that happened i feel like different
things like that happen like you said um
the guy in minneapolis
[ __ ] like that started happening right
and even people that was like
would call me and they'd be like no what
you're saying is right but you know you
can't say that like that in public why
the [ __ ] can i this is rap y'all didn't
tell me the rules before i got into this
[ __ ] i'm watching i'm thinking
i'm thinking these people really [ __ ]
doing power drives and really doing
clotheslines i'm thinking this is what
really happens right oh it's fake it's
not real
but i didn't know that i didn't find it
out until i do some real [ __ ] then it's
like whoa what's going on and then like
you got to think at the end of the day
anybody that got a problem with what i
said took my suicide if you go against
me you got something with wrong what i
got to say
and take it up with god you got
something to say with the whole bible
that's my only back and that's what i'm
standing on i'm standing on that so i
want the same people that got some
uh against what i got to say make sure
you say i don't [ __ ] with god i don't
[ __ ] with no religion that speaks
against that
anything
that you can't be a [ __ ] hypocrite
i'm i don't i don't deal with the
hypocrisy it's coney that's a fact